have you seen the churches these days
have you seen Church no but I'm not
talking I'm not talking about a man that
just goes to church I'm talking about a
man that has a relationship with God
there's a big difference and I will find
no I don't want a priest because there's
a lot of priests that don't have a
relationship with God they just want to
make money from CH but the key word is
you said want every man wants to cheat
that's like asking a man not to be a
every guy he when he says every every
man when they see a hot girl wants to
her come on come on Natural
Instinct yeah but the that love is
supposed to take over it's about loving
too you know you got love yeah you might
have the desire but it's about going out
better